hey guys this is dense the founder hey
Kiara and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is our review on the Gotham
trailer and Buzz the new TV show that's
coming out on Fox that is basically it's
really about Commissioner Gordon hmm but
obviously we were gonna have some Bruce
Wayne in a young Bruce Wayne gotta have
that seems young villain when the hot
parents can feel I I really like the
trailer I like the tone of it I thought
it looked good like you know we've been
hearing about the show for a little
while but I was kind of on the fence cuz
I'm like well is this gonna be actually
like kind of dark like the the movies
the Nolan trilogy or is this gonna be
something light-hearted almost CW ish it
looks like a combination of Nolan and
Tim Burton mm-hmm like they kept that it
looks dark like Nolan but they kept that
noir kind of look like Bullock like in
his brown coat and you know it just
looked like that kind of dark but I kind
of like the Tim Burton especially the
first Batman Tim Burton movie and it
looks good you know it's just I mean
it's it's funny because you have a call
its like before Catwoman but like it's
just like little girl poison ivy's like
this little weird girl I'm Holies like
you know plants around it's just it's
gonna be like it's it looks good it does
look good my concerns i know you've your
night talking with us already i'm a the
team that's behind it from CSI the
mentalist very successful shows huge
show some of the biggest shows on
television I just don't want this to be
a cop procedural not saying it well I
hope it's not I hope it's not but you
have to remember Brunner Heller whose
show running the show he also did Rome
which was a fantastic series I mean the
second season wasn't as good as the
first season but that's not his fault it
was they all they try to enjoy they try
to condense three right you know three
seasons into one so I I have faith you
know I'm not worried about the whole
Mentalist thing because I feel like he
probably signed on for that knowing what
he was supposed to do he delivered what
they want and they want a procedural
they gave him procedural this probably
will have some of that but hopefully you
know with with Commissioner Gordon
they'll they'll make a bigger story line
with that no I like the casting of a ben
mckenzie most people known from the OC
or
southland uh he looks like a young
Russell Crowe was good yeah and it
reminds me of one of my favorite movies
LA confidential Russell Crowe he played
the Cobb bud white right and ben
mckenzie he looks like he's kind of
bringing a little of that to this to
this role yeah it looks good i love
Donald lotions & Sons of Anarchy
previous season for the whole year he's
been in Vikings for a season and a half
of Vikings so I mean he's it's for some
affection without a full beer so he
looks different but I know it's nice
seeing him Jays gonna use in tier
terriers terriers yep yep FX Jenna pagan
looks good I think I believe she's
playing Penguins like I think she's the
big boss yeah she's like the head boss
over it's a new created characters for
this show which is cool i like Jada pink
I've always you know enjoyed her and
what she's anything she's done a solid
job so it's nice to see her back doing
some things you know again I love that
Fox of all this to do is beside CW CW is
a lot of geek stuff they take chances
with this genre stuff more than NBC more
than a bc i think but i just hope they
don't mess with the formula i mean i'm
not i mean everybody else gets on Fox
like Fox blew the day they messed up
firefly or you know they screwed up on
almost human almost human they almost
screwed up friend almost good of friends
cuz they this people they release
episodes out of order i hope they just
let this show just do its thing whether
it fails or not just let it let it go
just let it do its i think they will
just because of the name because it is
all based on the Batman franchise its
Gotham they didn't do a pilot thing the
orders here yeah they went straight to
series 13 episodes is going to air and I
think the fall probably
september-october yeah so hopefully
they'll get i'm pretty sure they're
probably like show the pilot at off at
comic-con oh those shoulder Comicon for
sure and get that buzz going right get
people on that and hopefully if you make
a story that has a big long story are
you can't show them out of order that's
the thing no so like almost human
because it was like very episodic they
were able to move it around and but if
they make it so like okay this this
episode leads into this one and this one
and this one then they
can't do that yeah I know if they don't
I mean they didn't do it with Sleepy
Hollow which is one of my favorite shows
of this past fall and that's going to be
a great line if they I mean premier
Sleepy Hollow and Gotham on Fox like
when that's the near time / that'd be a
great hour of just really good tell or
two hours of television i would probably
separate the nights but that's gonna
beat a couple good shows coming in
they'll be to see what they do like how
much you focus on Gordon even though
looks like it's a Gordon show how much
we're gonna see you Bruce how much
you're gonna see a little poison ivy
little cat it's like a bunch of mini
me's young Pena and young Riddler like
how is this all would they ever if this
is so successful in two or three years
I'm just spouting out there's what they
ever consider aging Bruce or is he I
don't see sales old I don't Batman TV
series I don't think so I think I'm
bring arrow on now those be great Nessus
League this is a self-contained right
right out the bat they said this has
nothing to do with the Cinematic
Universe this is not going to cross over
with arrow which is great with with with
Warner Brothers and I mean it's good and
bad their Cinematic Universe kind of
sucks right now or compared to Marvel
sounds good but thinking dude ever they
want arrow can do whatever they want
this show can do it everyone yeah I
consider this more of like an alternate
reality type of series and some people
got upset you know because I heard some
complaints like they some purists are
like oh these characters aren't that old
and and they weren't around with Batman
was here I don't care good sign on the
book world they change things all
exactly so my favorite comic book series
have our alternate universe oh yeah like
el cajon com yeah come what Yuma call it
uh red sighs old man Logan like all
these things that are alternate
universes that don't have to be
connected or tied to what is considered
canon yeah hopefully people this have
fun with the show and you know joy for
what I hope it's more like Arawa they
just like like the preview just throw a
bunch of people in there just have a
good time with us have fun I think so I
you know Milan concern yeah is more of
the episodic versus a big story arc and
maybe they will start off a little
episodic at first yeah like a mystery
here mystery there was so many villains
they have to kind of bring exactly and
then eventually get into something
bigger but I i I'm looking yeah I'm
excited for especially cuz it looks like
even you take away the name Gotham you
take away all
all the connection to the let's say the
Batman universe it still looks like a
good crime drama yeah yeah and so if
they can just weave in the comic book
aspects in it mm-hmm it's even got the
colonel from the wire yeah you know it's
got one of the actors from the wire in
there so yeah hopefully hopefully yeah
that's good alright guys so let us know
what you thought of the trailer for
Gotham are you looking forward to this
series are you upset that it doesn't
follow exactly what the comic books are
are you okay with that you can post your
comments below on the website think Eric
amor on our YouTube channel think Harold
pro make sure to subscribe to that you
can also can find all of us on twitter
dennis michael myself i think here let
us know what you think of all these new
comic book shows you know we got Marvel
work on their daredevil stuff over on
Netflix we have Gotham coming out for
Fox you have arrow on the CW marvel's
agents of shield on ABC all these great
shows to talk about paint on which ones
you like hoping shows to talk about you
know like I said right thing here oh and
i'm at griffin d we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero fans in and make sure like that
page and share our videos on Twitter
Facebook and all that stuff
you